you're warm good news socks fresh out of
the dryer oh i do love that ooh
feeds these are cold boom now they're
warm and
and human warm sock rossi ross mac yeah
well thank you so much hi hi
hi um
speaking of coming out warm from
something our first story is kind of
that great transition
what does stephen king make for dinner
great question well we've got the answer
and it's chilling
in today's food news
okay
[Applause]
so the new york post reports that
stephen king is horrifying fans yet
again but this time with microwaved fish
he posted this recipe on twitter for a
man who's written thousands of pages
it's so simple it's actually scary
get a nice salmon fillet
not too big
put some olive oil and lemon juice on it
wrap it in damp paper towels nuke it in
the microwave for three minutes eat it
i'm sorry for what do you have oh god no
you do not
it's not carbs
okay it's not carbs rasi i feel so
honored that i didn't that i'm not
shoving a bagel or a pizza or a
fettuccine alfredo down there it's
always a croissant or something here um
i will say
i can't believe he microwaves his fish
for a man who wrote fire starter you
can't light a flame hello
um all right so we're both going to try
this you're going to try it
all right i'm going to do a little lemon
just like you said i have to say it does
look really nice i got scared and i was
like i'll let ross try it and now i'm
looking at it and i'm thinking i made a
mistake all right i'll be i'll tell you
i'll be i'm not afraid of a little
microwave all right
[Music]
stephen king
there's nothing fishy going on here
it actually it's flaky it works
what
that's like
that's
like a
twist i didn't see coming it's actually
delicious you're true
well
i i
i'll tell you a story about stephen king
instead of eating the salmon you want to
just smell it no understood
i you know stephen king i went to stay
at his house because i did fire starter
with him and then um i did this movie
cat side with him which was really just
stories taken from his book night shift
and um so i got to go stay up at his
house in maine when i was a kid and it
was like the most joyful weekend of my
life um they had like a house that was
just like so filled with soul and his
wife tabitha and their kids and he made
pancakes in the kitchen and then his
office
was upstairs in the attic and he had a
pet scorpion named boris
so no salmon for me but that fun story
is what i will offer about stephen king
i love stephen king so much and you know
if he wants to add salmon to that
illustrious resume
microwave salmon so be it yeah
you know
you know why i love having a
conversation with you why because i can
go from microwave salmon to that one
time i'm at stephen king's scorpion
boris you know you just strap on you i
never know where it's going to take you
i didn't see that coming
[Music]